[Música]
y llegamos a buenos aires la capital
argentina para conversar con nuestro
corresponsal de natalio cos hoy sobre
esta crisis de política y económica que
vive argentina primero o natalio los
saludos muy buen día para ustedes ya en
buenos aires y que hubo que detalles se
conocen de este encuentro entre el
presidente alberto fernández y la
vicepresidenta recordemos que tenían
pues
disparidades después no estaban de
acuerdo en muchos temas también tras la
salida de este ministro de economía
martín guzmán con la llegada de la nueva
ministra entonces le pregunto qué
detalles se saben sobre este encuentro
que tuvieron en el en la casa de
gobierno
hola qué tal muy buenos días la verdad
es que son muy pocos los detalles no no
hay información que haya
salido más allá de rumores que son muy
difíciles de verificar en la
comunicación oficial del gobierno
insiste en que el gobierno está
trabajando en que está buscando salir
adelante en esta crisis seguir adelante
con el plan económico que había diseñado
el ahora ex ministro martín guzmán lo
dijo la nueva ministra de economía
silvina batakis que ella quiere
continuar con el mismo plan
económico incluso aseguró que había una
discusión muy grande en estos días sobre
la implementación o no de un salario
básico universal y quienes decían que no
era viable consideraban que las cuentas
fiscales no daban para sostener un
proyecto de esas características ella
salió a decir que no es algo que está
pensando el gobierno el trabajo más
fuerte el desafío más grande seguramente
aquí en argentina es contra la inflación
y contra esta situación de incertidumbre
que venían comentando ya en el programa
que genera no sólo estos incrementos
2 de precios sino también en algunos
casos faltantes de productos claro
natalio digamos cuál es el contexto como
llegó argentina hasta este punto vía
preocupante en términos económicos
a ver
hay varios elementos hay un contexto
internacional por supuesto y hay una
inflación histórica en argentina que no
se termina de resolver y en ese sentido
el control por ejemplo del precio del
dólar es clave y es algo que no está
pudiendo terminar de controlar el
gobierno y un dólar oficial al que
acceden muy pocas personas en algunos
casos por ejemplo importadores que ahora
además lo tienen restringidos y tienen
dificultades para acceder a dólares para
importación lo cual también está
generando algunos inconvenientes y una
serie de dólares paralelos para ahorros
a los que puede acceder cualquier
ciudadano si tiene la forma de
comprarlos algunos legales y otras
ilegales y este estos dólares son los
que muchas veces terminan marcando la
inflación entonces el control del acceso
a divisas también es clave en la
historia económica argentina reciente